thousands of brazilians rallied in
support of brazil's president jair
bolsonaro
they're backing his claims that brazil's
current electronic voting system
is not to be trusted
i believe bolsonaro was elected
president in the first round of the 2018
elections and not in the second round
like the official results say lawmakers
and judges must respect the will of the
people who want paper ballots
not just digital ones the president has
offered no evidence of
problems with the current system that
has been used since 1996
but his supporters believe him they want
a paper print out of every digital
ballot cast
and they're putting pressure on congress
and the supreme court
to change the system but 11 political
parties
and many brazilians question bolsonaro's
intentions
who says the people want to change the
electronic voting was there plebiscite
to ask what the majority of brazilians
want
there wasn't this is just the
government's way of distracting the
people from what is really going on
like the more than five hundred thousand
did by covert nineteen
recent polls show bolsonaro faces defeat
by former president luis inacio lula da
silva
if they contest next year's election
and bolsonaro has repeatedly said he
will not step down if he thinks there is
fraud
this is happening after the opposition
has staged four nationwide protests
calling for president jair bolsonaro's
impeachment
bolsonaro's popularity has waned in the
face of increasing
inflation unemployment and poverty rates
analysts believe he is following in the
footsteps of former u.s
president donald trump bolsonaro is
trying to do
the same thing that trump has done in
the election in the united states
he wants to have the
elements necessary to claim that
elections were rigged
and tried to invalidate them brazilians
still have to wait more than a year to
cast their votes
but bolsonaro's supporters and opponents
are already testing each other on the
streets
manuka yanaki of al-jazeera rio de
janeiro